there are so many quotes from your book
that I enjoy but this is one that spoke
to me I think this is one of the main
ideas of the book The identity synthesis
is a political trap making it harder to
sustain diverse societies whose citizens
trust and respect each other it is also
a personal trap one that makes
misleading promises about how to gain
the sense of belonging and social
recognition that most humans naturally
seek I thought that was very very
powerful thanks yeah and again you know
uh you're Chinese American and I'm sure
your cultural and linguistic Heritage is
important to you I'm Jewish and informed
not religious that is Meaningful to me
um part of a healthy sense of individual
identity will be those forms of
belonging to a particular group but I
think that the message that we are now
sending young kids in particular and I
really noticed this among the students
that I teach is to say that everybody
seeks recognition and society and they
want to be seen as themselves and that
is true I think what's true of nearly
everybody it's true of me it's probably
true of you but the way you seek that
recognition the way you find that sense
of being seen is to Define Yourself by
the particular intersection of
identities at which you stand and I
think that that is a false promise for
many people whose belonging in a
particular group might be marginal who
perhaps have one parent from one group
and one parent from another group and
another quiet scene has fully belonging
to either but but more importantly even
if you're fully a member of that group
it will never actually give you the kind
of recognition which all of us crave
which is that as being individuals as
well probably most people listening if
you have a sibling they're going to
share lots of identity groups with you
but you're not your sibling you love
them I hope hopefully get on with them
you share some interest with them but
you're not identical to them you're the
standing that you seek in society a form
of recognition you seek from your
parents from your family from society as
a whole goes beyond just that
intersection of identities and so I
worry that we're sending people a
message to seek validation from
something that can be a healthy part of
a self-identity but that can never fully
constitute it if they're actually going
to develop a healthy regard of selves in
a healthy sense of a place in society oh
yeah I'm very proud of my Heritage as a
child of immigrants but at the same time
um you know there are issues that affect
all of us I mean when I ran it was on AI
and automation
um and I dare say that's going to affect
uh just about everyone one reason why
your book
I I thought was really hard-nosed and
practical was that it actually details
how a lot of non-profits uh descended
into in inner turmoil uh and questioning
of their leaders and cultures over the
last number of years I know some of the
folks who run these organizations and
some of them actually say to me that
they are running scared of their own
employees which is by the way not what
you want when you're talking about in
many cases very Progressive not you know
non-profits which theoretically you know
I mean there's a lot of work for them to
do that there are some folks I know who
run these organizations who say it's now
their number one Criterion when they're
looking to hire someone is like is this
person going to ask for me to be fired
um X months from now and and that's like
their number one question as they're
screening I'm going to suggest that's
deeply unhealthy uh and a lot of these
orgs are doing very important work and
you hope that they're focused on the
work as opposed to focused on okay are
these people going to come from my job
uh down the road well absolutely
um and you know there's very strong
evidence of these cultural problems
within particularly Progressive
organizations that come from people who
have senior leaders within those spaces
people like Morris Mitchell who uh you
know is the head of a Working Families
party a long time organizer of a
movement for black lives
um who's written very powerfully about
the toxic atmosphere within these
institutions and and one of the reasons
for that is that
we've adopted a set of simplistic ideas
that make many claims uh unfortifiable
so you know in the book again I go
through in the first part of a book The
intellectual history of a sophisticated
version of these ideas talking about
people like Michelle Foucault and Edward
Saeed and Gayatri Spivak and Derek Al
and Kimberly Crenshaw and I disagree
with many of them in profound ways
um I have his pet peeve that people say
oh this is like going a little bit too
far I don't think it's going too far you
can't go too far and fighting racism and
sexism and discrimination I'm all in
it's just that that going in the wrong
direction that vision for society is
wrong-headed but be so sophisticated
smart thinkers I also Chronicle the way
in which we said yes if we become
popularized and sometimes vulgarized in
the form of thinkers like Robin D'Angelo
and IRA max candy and they really uh
have created this unforcifiable fourth
bubble uh right for for for for for
D'Angelo a white woman by the way
if you disagree with something she says
in her trainings
if you have a different view of a world
if you want to bring some evidence to
the table you're just demonstrating your
white fragility you're just
demonstrating but you're too insecure
and probably too racist to understand
the wisdom she's imparting for ibrahamex
candy
uh you know there's only racist and
anti-racists there's no in between
category there's no such thing as being
not racist and any idea or any
institution that has racially desperate
outcomes is by definition racist
including the United States Constitution
so effectively if you don't want to
scrap the United States Constitution you
are racist nothing to be done about that
and that kind of many key and world view
is part of what individuals within these
organizations can weaponize most people
Miss organizations are good decent
people who have genuine ideals for how
to make a better world but like in every
organization there's also some
sociopaths who like to exercise power
over their peers or who are narcissists
who think that they are the best thing
ever and any criticism of them is deeply
unfair and they have now been given
these tools to say if my boss criticizes
me that must be racist that must be
bigoted
and within Progressive organizations and
increases in mainstream organizations
there's no language to stand up to that
and so these few individuals within
these organizations who are often
mentally unwell can use this ideology as
a tool to just destroy by the internal
culture and these deeply damaging ways
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you